hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to a brand new let's play of
condemned criminal origins now this is a
game that everyone every button has been
like oh you got a plate so I guess I
gotta play it there's only a low game
because I was checking the sound I
didn't get any into it I immediately
quit out of soon-jong understand so here
we go if you already I am
internal reporting now it's done I'll
reveal a unexplained surge in crime rate
the city's crime rate has increased to
record-breaking levels the most
significant increase in assaults is
assault with deadly intent which is up
28% complete the game with only melee
weapon for an achievement award don't
care about that probably not gonna do
that
all right
No okay all right
ah I'm very interested in this game
because I haven't heard a lot about it I
mean I knew it existed but I haven't
actually done a lot with it in terms of
research so I I don't know this story
I know it's older so the graphic comment
I don't got all day here let's get a
move on okay whatever you say buddy so I
know the graphics aren't like incredible
or anything but it is meant I think this
is like on the PlayStation you were on
people are scared we need to get this
one follow me bodies this way maybe it
wasn't I have no idea when the first one
is released but I'm getting too old for
this oh that's what all the police used
excited to die first see what did I put
why did I put his duck hey I thought I I
thought I did he thought I did see shift
are I got look I'm sorry for being lame
I know this is the worst she you know
check cranky what huh oh maybe it's just
as action oh it's nothing outside the
bodies in the building oh my go Bonnie's
run as we speak
alright ha the patrolman on duty said
there was a mannequin involved Oh
a matchmaker well damn city's crawling
with sick killers no do I'd you have to
say manikin no uh-uh
God why do they always have to kill in
such maggot infested dumps I get they
pick a nice spot without addicts and
gang members for once someplace not so
damn dark okay all right this sounds
like a good idea
Jesus Shh nearly shot the bastard hey
you didn't even have a gun
this place is creeping me out
yeah whatever I'm fine I guess I got to
be brave enough for the both of us
because you all out there know how brave
I is and was were come like that
I know this guy's gonna die isn't he yep
you got that your stupid car broke my
light but kind of turn yours on
I hear you're afraid of the dark oh yeah
well it's true but shut up dick but
that's your name officer dick
oh hello Becker here FBI on the scene
over and out
a we're FBI okay agent Thomas this is
officer Becca Becca found the body on
Patrol okay
agent hi I see it I see the mannequin ha
ha ha ha oh there's more of them oh my
oh my oh oh no Thomas come on Thomas
all right Rosa I have to get on this one
a little bit I'm wireless data transfer
system enables you to investigate and
collect evidence at the scene of the
crime and transmit it to me for analysis
what I am results I'll contact you where
your cell phone
okie-dokie right let's get to work now
let's start by determining the cause of
death
Oh your instincts tell you eminence is
nearby prepare a forensic tool Oh
the system also like the correct tool
for you so don't worry about that all
right
ok my instincts what is my press-ready
tool to use tool I gotta look that up
too
I'm lame high no keyboard ready to tee
got it oh right on Tess let me access
save because I never know our prior pone
again all right so ready tool use the UV
light on the corpse and find the trauma
point a bright purple well there it is
action anything
this guy well this is a mannequin oh
okay I thought oh whoops all right so I
see it
see ah okay
huh yeah I see backwards in four ah here
we go okay there we go
No so I fail on that one I think it did
OOP huh wait but ah could tell yeah CSRF
a big [ __ ] strangled by how's the
virginity forcible fingermarks clear
except bruise intensity and against the
killer's right-handed missing the index
finger okay there must be something for
something we're not seeing
maybe on the Vatican's
pleasedon't operative this games full of
mannequins I would be
oh there's nothing I hate more than
broccolis flying over the crime scene
and if there's evidence it will show up
a prank read hey Becca get the lights
the agents laser works better in the
dark oh it's not oh boy
up here you oh boy okay
[ __ ] your donk
okey-dokey got a cool actually see I
like it
exact same MO as the others it's the
work of a guy we've been calling the
matchmaker kills young women violently
poses them in grisly tableau with meal
department store mannequins yet again
always slightly just figure mark on the
face yeah hmm any luck on the mug book
searches I bet the killer has the same
mark oh there's too many mention of
mannequins in this one spoken at a crime
scene I don't smoke well someone was ah
what that he disappeared Oh what it's
coming from in here
you look vanished what the hell is that
coming from here huh
what isn't his jacket see FBI dang it I
can smell the cigarette smoke okay
whatever crazy
Oh
he's right above us call for backup now
this is officer Becker we need backup
immediately Forte that's me attention
homicide suspects still in building copy
that
Becker and I will head up the fire
escape you wait here for backup uh [ __ ]
okay now he's playing with us change of
plans
Becker secure that door Thomas check out
the building and get these lights back
on why me why me
aah all clear agent no it's not you're a
liar
you're a dirty dirty liar finish up here
the better
yeah it's go liar wait I thought you
were gonna wait I thought change of
plans okay no and for Christ's sake be
careful yeah whatever
I'm anything but careful I'm a loose
cannon I'm a cop on the edge except FBI
agent not yet I don't want to tear her
mannequins out there Thomas
officer picker okay I don't know if
they're on a head drug Thomas tickets it
this one coming your way
addict amped up on something that's not
good that's not good at all why is that
that way that it is federal agent come
out peacefully or I will use force aah
oh god yeah jeez
oh yes I said he swallow them down
Thomas oh good anacs bank runs iconic
individuals con terribly bad oh come on
all kinds mostly violent be careful yeah
ah at least they're not as the horribly
disfigured monsters actually I'm pretty
sure that'll come later it always does
in these type of games whatever drug
they're on Oh kick yeah take that I know
you were already down but oh yeah ow
buthow blipped ow I like that
Chuck Norris kick come here anybody hey
anybody I need to try to get the lights
back on right are to check him oh oh oh
interesting very interesting
no crosshair on here though so that's
kind of hard I guess I adds to the
realism
I can't even sight down my gun it's
really quiet up here
come out come out wherever you are
oh boy the eyes I don't like this I
don't like this all right that doesn't
seem to be anything up here um all right
can't sprint ah where where okay I'm
okay
Hey ah boom I don't think that'll hide
you probably here we go
BAM uh-oh
maybe you were cowering in fear and I
just murdered you well I'm part of the
FBI so it don't matter right you didn't
see anything out there
okay that was to those four four ships
oh now I can sprint okay why do I need
to sprint something gonna happen
ah I see you come back here alright I
can deal with these guys
nothing too terrifying hello come here
stop running get over here
whoa ah all right okay get over there
hey how do I get over there yeah hurt ow
no yes I can even jump OOP no okay oh
not that way
ah what now
what do I do that does not seem to be a
way did ways be out where did he come
from
ha ha lid ow okay well it would have
been much cooler if I could have kicked
the door open but I guess I can oh oh
I'm mr. smokey I see your secrets now
kick here John what the hell oh no my
gun
hey are you mr. smokey don't don't don't
even think about it don't know what die
all right
the suspect has your gun yeah that
sounds like smart idea good why do now
I'm defenseless I'm defenseless many
items like these can be used as melee
weapons like what like what need to wait
to buy for grab oh that's what I'm
talking about
Farah 2x4 that's a darn short booth at
the way all right I am actually all out
of time
well I am actually interested in this
game that is kind of cool so let me know
what you think of this game there's
gonna be a long-running series I think I
think this is somewhat lengthy compared
to yo the custom stories I normally play
so let me know what you figure the
comments below and thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part bye-bye